if you notice Biz being started really
winning a lot when drug testing came in
I'm not saying I'm just saying and I'm
not you went a lot before too though he
did yeah but I'm saying maybe the guys
that were cheating I mean Peter Belfort
made him go blind because he was on all
the acai and we'll kicks
he's amazing stuff he kicked his eye off
he's the guy still went to become world
champion oh his story's insane he fought
almost 10 or 15 fights after bitter make
him blind incredible for an I had to
[__] Super trt Bro I was training
with him at rain and I'm like you can't
see this he's like no I'm like where the
[__] are you gonna fight you go in there
and win yeah
told me he could see the side of the
nose that one of my favorite fights of
all time crazy